[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
to make america great again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they
[Music]
tweet like
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
to make america great again
[Music]
[Music]
will take the wheel and drop the train
these hands
[Music]
my fingers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
baby welcome to the world famous
stuttering john podcast with your
favorite world famous host stuttering
john melendez how are you everybody
it wasn't rigged you're just a loser
city of the midas touch brothers
who
sent me that shirt i'll be wearing it
proudly today as i go to my pub
and uh deal all the republicans
it's my third show in a row i did a beer
on the balcony with my best buddy mikey
stein
that was on sunday
yesterday i did a special stern show
which was just me and monique from radio
gunk
you know talking about
all the gossip and
rumors that are abound when it comes to
howard and the rest of the gang over
there
and then today we go back to politics
where i will have uh tony michaels
coming on
as well as house sparks
and then on thursday i have uh a member
of congress
coming on so i got some good guests
always
there's a lot
a lot who are coming on that you guys
are going to be very happy about
joni eisenberg first in the room hi
johnny to see politics girl latest video
marrying children
everyone should see this i will check it
out
the squeegee um we're all in the mood
for a melody
and you got me feeling all right
tony heisenberg this just keep coming
trump said yes in regards to election it
was there for the taking brazenly
talking about how the election could
have been stolen
need we say more merrick
marjorie trailer green wants us to get
over january 16 american people are fed
up with this
over dramatization of a riot that
happened here at the capitol one time
um
hey uh
three toes
once
it's too many
okay
uh joni heisenberg uh the videos of
shanghai uh residents shouting from
their high rises over covert lockdowns
reminds me of the scene from the movie
network the drone warnings exemplify a
dystopian
but it's society
as hell and i'm not gonna check it
anymore
admiral solo can scott the engineer join
you in dc when you interview republicans
we're all very excited that you're going
and rooting for you to embarrass the gqp
is he's in florida he's not now
pat costiano i think uh gonzo is going
to be there marquee v193
sheryl dorbar doug goodstein can't make
it for health reasons
but he said he'll get me a crew stage
dog
and i emailed the
press department again to get them to
try and get me some credentials after
all
this podcast has been talked about on
many news networks many times mark
hurley thanks for the um
oh nothing uh mark harley from ireland
uh shorty won jm vandy with the badge
robert myers i called my friend in vegas
robert
so uh i'm just waiting to hear back from
leslie ramsden
uh
mark b with the badge
sherry p cb
uh
mexicali maggie
king of the best guess that's true
facebook people during this broadcast
you can support my page by sending stars
a digital gift that helps me earn money
but jeanette cook is doing errands what
is that
uh benny loco my mod is here
roberta knight
uh martha salinas
nancy cox
forrest richie greetings and salutations
from the high castle in the forest of
bizarre on the banks of the licking
river
tmi
nikki b is here my moderator
william zavala kenny gill from melbourne
australia
alien elizabeth moran hey from new york
john i'm not in the city but i'm reeling
over the shooting today so am i
so am i really sad
my thoughts and praise go out to those
families
uh
in new york hit the freaking subway
paula bradley
hello from extremely windy kansas we hit
the wind this morning in california
wayne berkey
i was christina garcia
trina mine i was supposed to go to the
dentist today to get this tooth fixed
but
last night i took an edible from like an
old one i had
from speedweed because i couldn't find
any of my dubies
and i guess it was like 10 you know uh
uh
milligrams or whatever because
i couldn't sleep it was sativa so
so i was uh i just was up all night so i
just postponed tomorrow to get the
toothpicks stacy hogan
lyndon mcewen
but i'm scared crap the dentist anyway
uh a whistle zero three four
janelle walker
uh paula bradley
uh t-wheeler0814 type me
uh
let's see
christina montarbo russell johnson three
days in a row yes i'm on the island
gerrard sullivan janet taharjan from
windsor ontario canada
um uh yvonne watkin
ginger artra silence
uh gerard sullivan billy joel pride of
hicksville new york yep pretty close to
me
uh linda mcewen janie buck
debbie garrettson
gerard sullivan
jody nelson robertson
lynette kuowa kelly golemba
i don't know i don't know if the magic
got to my mom's year
tony macaroni from norway
andrea brower
uh
jill carter benny loco i say linda mckee
and jackie hobson uh trying to get to
the end here because i see i got tony
waiting in the wings robert reynolds
uh
thank you there robert uh myra hamilton
little from moet scotland
okay i'm hitting my i'm hitting the
scottish yard tomorrow
the scotland yard that's our other pub
phillip seaver we have a few
j.j sullivans as well
uh anita blake
and uh depends we have some we have our
favorite bartenders so we
go
to rod sullivan ah the sunrise mall is
closing this year that's a shame
uh
yeah michelle johnson warner chunky do a
shout out to both my kids it's their
birthday tomorrow
happy birthday logan
and happy birthday abby
there you go
and now
without further ado i'm going to bring
on the guy who's looking down right now
this is tony michaels
sorry i was looking at my phone i was
making sure my tweet went out i was uh i
was tweeting out that i was uh coming on
the show so i wanted i wanted to make
sure tell everybody come on over and and
chat with everybody here so yep uh thank
you i'm betty loco thanks for the two
bucks let's see if the super chat works
awesome
yeah yeah we had a good time you know uh
yeah how are you john
i'm good i'm good
it was funny you were getting
you were starting to get the hate from
my trolls oh yeah yeah yeah i i messaged
you the other day because um i um the
the stuttering john melendez trolls are
some of the best i mean they they really
are relentless and they do not give up
and they i mean this guy wrote like a
whole uh uh memo in my youtube video i'm
like man i wish you would come back
every day and write the same you know
a memo every day really critique me
um you know the crazy part is he said
that um
i paid
i think it's uh i paid you to come on
your show and i was like and and he said
i think he said 300
and of course he went on this long
diatribe about how liberals are bad and
you know liberals are stupid and all you
know this whole thing this i mean it was
it took me about 20 minutes to read the
whole damn comment yeah and at the very
end i said
you have got it completely wrong
i had to pay john 5 000 to come on his
show
not 300 get it correct if you're gonna
get it correct all that stuff he said
about liberals that's absolutely true
but i did i paid john five thousand no i
don't i don't think you charge anyone to
come on your show i would never charge
it yeah i don't think so i didn't think
so i didn't think so i mean i mean if
like if if a podcast wants me to be a
guest in person right i'll charge them
because right right right but here on
here on the virtual internet it's it's
so easy right it's yeah no i mean i've
been on tons of
yeah yeah no i don't try do you imagine
me
you know what i felt like though i felt
like at first i was like oh my gosh john
charges 300 hours beyond spy i got a
hell of a deal i got on for free that's
i thought i got like i thought i got
like a coupon or something like oh my
god this is this is fantastic no no no
no that's the thing like uh
they don't get anything accurate
everything that they always say well
absolutely it's all horseshit yeah well
you know just like these trump
supporters they believe in fantasies oh
but you know
they do this they do this type of stuff
um you know like got this whole disney
thing uh so the news comes out that ron
desantis is a bigot right he signs the
don't say gay bill and and basically
disney's like [ __ ] your don't say gay
bill you know and they're you better
change it or you know you can count us
out and so ron desantis says disney is
woke well the real story is the real
story is is that disney actually
actually gave contributions to some of
the people that were on this bill now
they have since turn their backs on
those contributions that we will not
contribute to those people again and the
reason why is because if we remember
there was a walkout at disney of the
employees at disney world
when they were pushing that bill to the
legislator and the ceo of disney
really to his credit he said you know
what you're right i should be on the
side of equality and equity for all and
i should be against this bill and disney
as a company that's something i can
control should stand against that
messaging of this bill that demeans that
the means people in the lgbt community
and makes them the other and ostracizes
them from society which is completely
wrong so disney is in the right ear
they're not woke and really honestly
disney was kind of a neutral player in
the build to begin with so this they
always exercise in fantasy like they
always exercise in complete [ __ ]
fantasy that's like this hunter biden
laptop [ __ ] when now we know that that
that jared kushner the son-in-law who is
in the white house did a 2 billion
dollar dirty deal with the saudi crown
prince
yep and we're supposed to be worried
about hunter biden's laptop give me a
[ __ ] break that's just all smoke and
mirrors
not to focus on the real story which is
donald trump is uh
you know is getting
i mean
what the hell is this what well right
and you know they're they're going to um
they're going to they're going to do
this more with this lieutenant governor
of new york you see he was arrested
today on
campaign bribery charges i guess and the
feds arrested him
this investigation has been a long time
coming i think it's been about a year
and a half that this investigation's
been that people have known about this
investigation but they're gonna use this
as a weapon you know like democrats
actually are okay with democrats when
they break the law getting prosecuted
like we're okay with that you know if
democrats break the law fine prosecute
them whatever put them in prison if they
deserve to be in prison but they're
going to say oh see the democrats are
the ones
when when when they're trying to pass
laws in tennessee to marry children
and and talking to katanji brown jackson
the first black woman to become the
supreme court justice complaining to her
and asking her questions about child
porn when their staffer at the rnc the
republican national convention committee
is being arrested and charged with child
pornography charges like the projection
just doesn't stop with these morons it
just does not oh no no it doesn't at all
yeah and you're right that like they are
like
this it's like
marjorie trailer green is tweeting out
today
you know um i carry guns stop taking our
rights away from us
it's like oh shut up i go you know what
instead of carrying a gun how about
carrying a brain you dumb freaking
jackass
i mean you do have the right to have a
brain in this country you do have that
right and maybe she should exercise that
right you know what's funny about that
is marjorie taylor green doesn't want
them to take her freedom away
for guns but they debt she definitely
wants them to take her liberty away in
the autonomy of her body i mean she is
the weaker of the sexes she said it and
uh maybe she's right she is weak she is
brainless um and but but they're okay
they're okay with oklahoma taking away
the liberty and autonomy of women's
bodies but they definitely used today
yeah that's right the oklahoma governor
signed it just so everybody knows
oklahoma banned abortion today full stop
oklahoma let me say that again
oklahoma banned abortion
right now if you're a woman in this
freaking great country of ours you have
got to be
appalled
and wait until these right-wing loons
start getting these
you know getting these women freaking uh
pregnant and then
having to try and get an abortion oh
well they'll have abortion see that's
the thing john it's the history of
abortion like abortion has always been
legal for rich people like rich people
have never been not been able to get an
abortion like rich white people oh rich
white conservative women will still get
abortions in this country in oklahoma
and everywhere else they'll still get
abortions they just won't be charged
with crimes i mean we've seen it in
texas this week they charged a woman
they charged a woman with murder with
murder in texas because she had a
medical procedure that some people
consider an abortion they charged her
with murder now luckily because of our
outrage um on the internet and elsewhere
in the in the media really because we
had such [ __ ] outrage about this that
they arrested a woman from on murder
charges because she had a medical
procedure uh because of that outrage
they dropped the charges but it doesn't
matter that's like them trying to pass a
law where they can marry kids in
tennessee and they'll go oh you caught
us being pedophiles so now we'll make it
to where they're 18. you don't get to
change it after you done did it you
[ __ ] fascist we know you you are we
[ __ ] see you and i'm gonna keep
calling them out and you know i know you
do too on this show yeah of course
but you're exactly right they are just
that i mean
they are fascists and there's no doubt
about it
you know if you look at the definition
of other fascists
it's them
right
right well i mean i always say the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not liberty um you know that's
kind of my my phrase it's in my my intro
on my show is that the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not liberty and what i i'm trying to get
people understand is
if they
come for one person just one person
maybe it's a trans child maybe it's
someone in the lgbt community maybe it's
a woman in oklahoma maybe it's to to
convict a woman of murder in texas for
having a medical procedure they're gonna
come after you they're gonna come after
you and they even wanna take consent
away from parents with their children
that's what they're doing with these
trans athlete laws um they're acting
like it's a girl boy thing and and it's
a it's an athletic and competition thing
what they're trying to do
is take consent away from parents for
their children so they're wanting to
marry them and they're wanting to take
your consent away from you for your kids
it's disgusting
and as far as i've richie just wrote in
um from facebook an 11 year old gave
birth last week
results of a rape that's sick right that
is just sickening and again that's what
they want to do they want to take
consent away from you from your children
and it's not like th the marriage law
and all this pedophilia um it isn't like
women grown women wanting boys it's all
white old wrinkly ball sacks obsessed
with little bitty girls like in this
case or the 11 year old girl they want
to take consent the state the government
they want to use the government to take
your consent away from your 11 year old
daughter who is raped that's what they
want to do not to generalize but it's
the same thing with the catholic church
i mean here they you know go crazy over
all these sins and all the horrible
things and then and then they're
molesting boys
well
right well i mean it is a lot of
projection and it is because they're
you know they're completely obsessed
with other people's sexuality
or no it was shakespeare right they'll
protest
those elections
way way way too much i mean they you
know they're passing bills to actually
sexualize kids gender in schools like
kids gender is not i think we talked
about this on the last show it's gender
is not a sexual thing you're making it a
sexual thing because you think genitalia
and your gender has to do with sex
because you're a [ __ ] weirdo
um gender is just what you identify as
this is that when everyone asks this
question like they asked judge brown
jackson what is a woman i was like the
correct answer is it's a gender that a
person identifies as like that's what a
woman is that's that's right it's a
gender that a person identifies as check
this out a line of judea a tennis
congressman tennessee congressman has
a 16 year old wife that just gave birth
to a child i mean
16 years old in tennessee
well uh if the parents give consent but
imagine imagine if they want to have
child brides and then they want to take
the consent away from the parents for
the children that's what they're doing
they're they're systematically little by
little using the government whether it
be state and they want to have federal
government they want to have federal
power to do this they want to take
consent away from you from your children
so because they they don't just want
your children's minds they want their
bodies and they're coming after them and
and if you don't believe me you just go
back in history and look at what they
did um in history with fascism and it
will tell you it will tell you what they
did hey tony i'm gonna you know since
you mentioned uh desantis
i'm gonna play you something from this
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay let's see it yeah
okay now this is
now this kind of reminds you of nazi
germany of what they would do to the
journalists right ron desantis ron
desantis reminds me a lot of of nazi
germany
okay
so
now let me just so what's going on now
this is a this is a press conference for
uh uh ronda sanders he sees people in
the crowd
he sees a couple of reporters that he
doesn't like
what they do to him
are you are you pressed
i'm sorry you're not in our hearts
we have a screening constitution are you
guys afraid of questions i just wanted
to ask the governor governor about the
624 million dollar tax report for
wealthy corporations
including the 10 million that business
can i get from our tax dollars so you
guys should ask about that
corporations are going to get a 624
billion corporate tax refund from this
legislature
and this league is going to get 10
million dollars
why are you guys assaulting a person
how
freedom of press right john
it doesn't end there watch
excuse me can i get my microphone please
do you suspect me of committing a crime
okay thank you very much
i would love to ask governor desantis
about rental inflation
rental inflation is four times the
weight in the world of national friends
of questions the media you should ask
them about that can i have your name and
badge number officers please name a
badge number
you can exercise
you can exercise your freedom on speech
on the other side
it's not freedom of speech they're the
press
it's so [ __ ] ridiculous
now obviously i got to run a lot of
press conferences but that was
really stupid questions
these guys are trying to ask him about
this tax cut he's given to all the rich
that's a legitimate question
from your constituents right and he
doesn't want to hit so he does what
trump does just get him out of here
right well the other thing too is they
seen the one the one person recording it
and the person recording it and they're
like nope got to get him out of there
too he'll post it on social media
um you know and and that's you know a
lot of people complain about social
media and like oh well it's a swamp and
you know the right wing but hey let me
tell you something i tell everybody on
my show you cannot look away from this
stuff we have to watch these videos like
the video this morning uh at the subway
car of the where they you know this the
the shooter uh at sunset park i guess he
it sounds like he he lit some kind of
smoke bomb or some kind of smoke device
in the subway car and then started
firing
now i actually believe you know thinking
about it in my mind with logic i'm like
i'm kind of glad he set off the smoke
bomb he on a he had on a gas mask i
guess but a gas mask doesn't like make
you see through the smoke it just keeps
you from inhaling the the smoke so uh
hopefully i think it impaired his
envision his vision so he wasn't able to
uh it doesn't sound like anyone's uh
mortally wounded at this point which is
a good thing um that no one's uh has a
fatal wound that they're just injured uh
so so thanks thanks for that but um
but you know it just it we have to watch
this stuff we have to see this stuff
because if people realize like with this
reporter being escorted out like holy
[ __ ] if if ron desantis is willing to
skirt the right of the free press which
is a constitutional right guys the
freedom of press is written into the
constitution and this guy is willing to
just
[ __ ] all over that he is willing to [ __ ]
on you and he is willing to [ __ ] on your
rights and he is willing to [ __ ] on your
constitutionality whether you like it or
not or you like him or he you like him
[ __ ] on certain people's
constitution
constitutional rights he's coming after
yours next if he doesn't like you what
don't you understand about that is it
doesn't matter if you like who he's who
he's attacking now
what happens when he comes after you
what the [ __ ] are you going to do what
the hell are you going to say i just i
don't understand it no it but but like i
was
i was relating it
to your point about who's woke here
that's right i mean who's who's well ron
you can't handle a couple of legitimate
questions it's not the stuttering john
you know what do you read you know while
on the bold type questions right no this
is real you know real
questions that you should be able to
answer and you get them thrown out you
are a [ __ ] ronnie well and that is
freaking you are a [ __ ] that that is
the main point is they are snowflakes
they're snowflakes and that's uh
ultimately
you know uh where we need to fight them
at it because they want to die online i
will be moving to florida in about two
years already oh are you you already get
the plans to move to florida yeah and i
already looked at the place that i want
to go to and let me just tell you
something
i'll be out there i i will be freaking
going
nuts going to these press conferences
what makes you want to move to florida
is there something specific
i like the warm weather okay all right i
like the beach i want to get a boat like
i used to have and then take it out on
the golf you know maybe maybe you could
buy mar-a-lago in a on the courthouse
steps when it uh when it goes
when he when he can't afford to keep it
anymore and he can't afford to pay the
taxes he'll put it on the courthouse
steps maybe i read somewhere that is
you know that is how i mean that his
office was uh searched
well uh you know i wouldn't be surprised
that lauren windsor has a video out of
john eastman
there's some speculation john eastman's
in some big trouble because he went to
the wisconsin legislator and he was
pressuring the wisconsin legislator this
is just just recently
even after
all the questions about the illegality
that has happened with his memo he's
going to state legislators and still
pressuring them to overturn election
results that are already certified this
[ __ ] crazy idea that they can still
make donald trump the president they
really are focused in on this and and
people need to pay attention to this the
reason why they're still focused on
donald trump being the president united
states is because he's the only one that
will pardon them for the crimes that
they committed while they were trying to
commit a coup
like he's saying it on stage at his
[ __ ] nazi rallies he's like we need
to make sure that the january six
insurrectionists are are taken care of
and they're they're pardoned and you
know we need to do all this like he
literally is telling you out loud that
he wants to be the king so that way he
doesn't go to prison and none of his
lackeys go to prison like that's what
he's saying and they're getting closer
and closer did you see the um
you know the proud boys were arrested a
couple weeks ago and enrique tario which
is he's an interesting character but
there was his lieutenant i think his
name is donahoe i think is his name is
his last name he pled guilty to
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding and a few other charges but
that was one of the charges that he pled
guilty to
and the craziest part about it is that
is the same charge that the judge carter
in california who made the decision
about the john eastman emails that the
january 6th select committee
can have those emails that's the same
thing that he said he said no you can
charge the president and he's sorry tony
i have to i have to stop for a second
what do you got what do you got
i
i'm really shocked by this news
and
i have to just say
uh
to rest in peace uh gilbert godfrey
oh no he just died at the age of 67. and
whoa that's way too young yeah
i'm seeing that i'm seeing that now
that's uh i have so many great stories
with gilbert
he's in my book i talk all about the
all the times we hung out at at the
tonight show all the times that we hung
out
in manhattan and had lunch and
uh he's one of the funniest comics i've
never left he's such a he's such a
brilliant comment like he's always he's
always right there where you're at like
um anytime he's ever i've ever watched
him do comedy and there was one specific
um i forget what the last thing was but
he was kind of improving and i think it
may have been a jerry seinfeld where he
was improving uh stand up with with
jerry and he's just like the gilbert is
like inherently funny like he doesn't
even have to like write jokes i can't
believe it and uh let me just say my
thoughts and prayers to his two children
and dara kravitz godfrey dara
you know i you know what my condolences
gilbert was
one of the funniest comics i've ever
seen i i saw him at the brokerage pub
and i think it was me and billy west and
the couple and we couldn't stop laughing
we were crying tia i mean the guy was
oh he's hilarious comedy genius and
i can't he's 67 he has two young kids
god it makes me so sad man uh here here
in variety it says uh if you'll let me
read if that's okay gilbert godfrey a
comedian aladdin star and owner of one
of the most iconic voices in hollywood
has died after battling a long illness
his family announced tuesday he was 67.
so um sounds like he's been dealing with
an ongoing uh
ailment um i know he had something with
his stomach
but this is this is a heck of a blow to
the comedy community i mean he uh he
like so eccentric
yeah yeah and cheap and i'll just give
you a couple of gilbert stories yeah
yeah go ahead yeah now i would like to
hear that
this is how cheap that gilbert was and
by the way gilbert and i were eskimo
brothers uh he had shagged a girl then i
ended up following him with the same
girl
but i won't but she was super hot i
couldn't believe the gilbert and she
would tell me that she would go out to
the bar to meet gilbert he wouldn't pay
for anything she had to pay for it
give you just some funny stories with
gilbert
oh i'll give you a bunch i mean they're
all in my book but
uh
the first one is like me governor and
already i would have lunch after the
stern show
and it was at this uh it looks like this
pizza joint
and
after we're done now keep in mind i
lived on 14th street we were eating on
like 56th street
and gilbert lived on 23rd street so
which is like that's like and it's like
30 blocks and and like three avenues
so i say gilbert you want to share a cab
no no no no no you know i'll walk i'll
go hold on let me reword this gilbert do
you want me to pay for a cab uh for us
he goes yeah
so he so so he thought he thought maybe
you wanted him to pay for a cab and he
was willing to walk if it meant he had
to pay for a kid oh no he like he took
no no i said let's share a cake oh oh so
he he thought he was gonna have to pay
for like half of it didn't he yes but he
didn't want to do that
and and the girl that we both shagged
when she would go to his house
he would have
um his furniture was a lot of picnic
chairs
no [ __ ]
and and a closet full of toothpaste and
shampoo that he would take out of hotels
oh okay cause he you know because he had
to get the freebies right
yeah yeah but my favorite well here's my
favorite two cheap gilbert stories
gilbert and i were doing stand-up
i got him 10 grand to show one for
friday night so 10 for friday 10 for
saturday 20 grand
and we flew in first class to la
when when the show was on klsx
and this is at the grove theater theater
in anaheim
and
we land at lax
and you know like they just had get you
know served us breakfast
so they had like you know so we had the
pancakes right um
so
so the plane lands
and i look you know
gilbert's getting his uh bag on top and
i look at
i look at his seat
and he's got like
a half a bottle
of one of those tiny little shot glass
kind of uh
a maple syrup bottle right
and
so i see a half of it so he used half
so
i get up to get my bag i look back down
at the chair
and
and and the bottle's gone i go
gilbert you didn't take that half bottle
of that tiny bottle of syrup the jiggles
you caught me didn't you
that's hilarious and he would bring two
suitcases to the tonight show
one for his clothes and the other for
all the free [ __ ] he can grab at
tonight's show
by each little lady you mean like in the
green room like they they would have
stopped
magazines right he would empty the candy
trays
because
did he have like did he have like ziploc
bags that he he would order two
dinners you know before the show one he
would eat the other he would bring back
to the hotel so he could have later so
he didn't have to buy food later
and then
one time me gilbert and billy bob
thornton
are hanging out in the hallway
and
and
billy bob is like such a humble guy he's
like gilbert i'm such a big fan of yours
i'm such a big fan
and gilbert was so uncomfortable
he just didn't know how to deal with it
i'm watching gilbert just like
oh
thanks i don't know what to do with them
and then the last one i'll tell you is
gilbert so i get him to close the show
already goes on before him
and his man just said well john you know
gilbert doesn't really
do well in l.a i go are you kidding me
you know he's a you know he's a comic
genius
so he's on stage i'm sitting behind bob
moore who's the gm who i convinced to
pay gilbert 10 grand a show and
gilbert's up there
and he's getting booed and they're
throwing
you know chicken wings at him and and
and stuff and instead of like even
flinching gilbert just started going all
right a guy and a girl walk into a bar
and what no i don't want to do that one
okay this guy and this girl are hanging
out having sex you know what i don't
want to do that one either and he kept
doing it and they kept booing and kept
throwing [ __ ] and he finally ends it
with the freaking um
uh
you know that great you know that long
joke that everybody the uh
uh not the fantastics the uh
come
on you gotta know how those are in the
room the uh
how tell me what it is hal
aristocrats
so
i'm yelling it into the void hey what's
happening tony how are you hey how are
you nice to digitally meet you
good i'm just flown in to be a momentary
wikipedia and then i will be released
okay good good getting in my own
recognizance yeah
and then bob moore the you know the uh
gm turns around and looks at me and goes
this is what i'm paying 20 grand for
how like you know the sad news today is
gilbert garfield just passed away
oh my god
yeah i i mean
i i did not know that i'm just finding
out um
yeah that's why i was telling some of my
like you know some of my best moments
hanging out with gilbert
it's uh yeah it's he's one of those
people that's hard to process
because uh as a fan i'm surprised
somebody didn't kill him a long time ago
um i i
it's uh because of the exact reasons
you're talking about um and i'm kidding
of course but he like he's one of those
people
that
sort of
you know how they do in sci-fi movies
they always use this hat concept of we
can get to them to mars without using
any fuel if we just whip around the sun
and the gravity will chuck us into deep
space all [ __ ] all [ __ ] but yeah
that's starting but yeah
that's yeah it's
the point is is that that's gilbert's
career
gilbert was very much
in a in a low earth orbit in danger of
of crashing into the atmosphere and
burning up well you know he did the one
night
he did the one time
with the aflac remember he did the 911
multiple times that's the no that's the
he didn't do 911 jokes he was doing
jokes about fukushima daiichi and the
and the
and the tsunami that's right
he was like right now
but don't worry another one's going to
float by in a little while yeah right
right right yeah yeah right
and again like
you know he was one of the first people
to be like he was the pilot for canceled
the series
multiple times you know they try to get
like you always hear these stories about
people trying to get a pilot on the air
for years and they had a pilot they
never went to series in a pilot never
went to series
he was like that was being canceled
it was like he was always piloting the
idea of being canceled and yet he would
always come back and he you know bless
his heart he you know he had the rickles
gift which is he looked like a frog so
he could kind of get away
with anything and there's a you know
there's a safety and a beauty in that
and some comedians just go well i'm kind
of [ __ ] to start with so why am i what
what what you got
you know what i got that you ain't got
is essentially gilbert's entire defense
mechanism and it was fantastic my first
introduction to gilbert besides as a
stand-up
as a character which i see i saw a lot
of people early 90s trying to copy their
version of gilbert at the laugh factory
particularly because the laugh factory
is a
it's a play-doh factory for character
pieces like if you want to be uh you
know a guy who juggles you know bowling
pins that look like your ex-wife and
tour on that for 20 years you you run
that gag at the laugh factory right but
the original guy who just improvs that
bit would never set foot in the place
right that's that's the laugh factor and
he's the he's the laugh inventor this is
the factory version right so there were
tons of dudes who would i would see them
come out and do this somewhere between
richard lewis and gilbert godfrey
version of touch your forehead and i i i
you know and
gilbert's just like
his a bit you know he he's one he likes
saggett is one of those guys who had a
freedom to just
be
brutal on stage in a you know as far as
being gross or what we
you know hilariously call offensive
these days
there's mass graves in ukraine and
people are like that joke made me feel
bad like okay [ __ ] oh this is how life
works you either live with jokes or you
you live in a society where someone's uh
shoveling dirt on you unceremoniously so
i gotta tell you i'm like i'm so sick
because he has two young kids and and
he's got a great yes yeah sweetheart of
a wife
and and if i could
be better if his wife sucked
what
like his wife like is his death would be
okay if his wife sucked if he it'd be
like like that's the hilarious part like
you know he's passed away
yeah
that's right exactly like and thank god
he died because his kids are fuck-ups
and his wife is awful right
i know you didn't i'm making the joke
about that oh my god you're not allowed
to offend you john sensitive
yes and i'm trying i'm i i'm trying to
do a joke that gilbert would be proud of
in his reference
i'm just in shock about the whole thing
because i got to tell you something i
mean i hung out with that guy a lot
you know i mean like you know so it's
right
reason number one why i'm surprised he
lived as long as he did
well that's a good that's a good uh i'll
tell you this
you know my favorite how do you ever see
him well i'm sure you've seen him do
stand up right
of course it's my favorite i loved him i
love gil i love gilbert and therefore i
will not be miserable in his memory
um i'm sad for his family
um and and and bless their hearts and i
have no doubt that they are both uh
saddened and relieved at his passing
as everyone will be with all of us let's
let's let's
take a moment for all the people who
when we die will miss us terribly and a
couple other people like well at least i
finally get to take his number out of my
phone right that's you know we all have
those people in our life so a moment
hats off to them
with pal
my favorite what
one of my favorite jokes that gilbert
did was i don't know if you remember
uh tony he would do a joke about the
last uh a supper
you know the painting and go hey how
come everyone's on the same side of the
table how come it's not like that you
know you know the people on this side
like
right
like he was so eclectic you know and
funny
you know accenture
well well like you said well he had a
lot of beard yeah he was so weird he
could get away with the weirdest things
like like that's right never you never
would expect what the hell was going to
come out of his mouth next because he
didn't have like well
either right
no there was no need for it and right
quite frankly because of his because of
his character on stage there was this
idea with gilbert where you kind of
expected him to do weird almost stephen
right obtuse observational [ __ ] just
because he seemed like such a character
and then when he comes out and does
basically old jokes from a book
essentially
that is the most obtuse
you know uh non-sequitur he could
possibly do is do old hack bits norm
mcdonald was very much the same way and
i feel like i love both of them for that
very thing is that ultimately they were
comedy purists and being weird wasn't
ever going to be enough
and there's a
the the genuine you know
uh beauty of gilbert and norm mcdonald
where their absolute devotion to to
laughter
that and it even
compares you know normally
yeah
yeah they had they had every bit within
them the writing capability to do
certain jokes that were you know
peculiar and funny because they were
peculiar but what they ultimately fell
back on was
what what's the lean in joke
and the lean in joke in a lot of these
situations is you and i are sitting at a
table uh you heard this one it's good
and not because it was offensive but
because we're sharing a moment right and
those kind of personality jokes being
able to do those on stage create that
same feeling the lean in feeling
um that you
created a table when somebody's being
awful in the place and you lean over to
your friend and you nail the the person
between the two of us that moment being
able to put that on stage and maintain
that kind of intimacy with the audience
in spite of being yeah yeah you know
this guy a
character or
you know in the middle of like which you
know both of them spoke like comedy
trombones from the 30s you know what i
mean like if you
if you didn't understand english and you
put norma mcdonald and gilbert godfrey
on stage it would sound like an old
comedy vaudeville band
right and the just the sound just the
sound would be funny just stunning
absolutely right
like that's how the two of them
yeah like he would do jokes about the
original planet of the apes that came
out and went like 68 and he would go uh
yeah pay no attention to the teeth
behind the teeth you know because
remember
you know in the original sure
like they had the teeth and then they
see the human playing the t right behind
them and he would do well i i get it
and not one person in the club would
would it were old enough to even watch
the damn movie no
well you know you know that's the other
thing that him and norm did was like
they were so committed no matter how
weird or how awkward that the joke may
be they were so yeah that joke that they
would see it all the way through like
they would never they would never
abandon it never bail on it right unless
it was all the way look gilbert gilbert
would gilbert would sometimes
bail on a punchline on purpose yeah
because it was it was great because it
was so obvious yeah it was so obvious
what the punchline was going to be that
actually saying it is less of a laugh
because you know
it's not even yours so it's not like
watch my wacky punch line that i thought
up because it's right you know it's from
a book from 1947. that soldiers read to
each other
so that they could have a laugh before
they ran into no man's land and stepped
on a mine and the only thing that got
back to their family was what's left of
their leg
right yeah these were dunkirk jokes
but i'll tell you he was one of those
guys like that i you know i would see
i'd see live and just
it was non-stop laughter like you
couldn't stop laughing he was that
[ __ ] great you know well even eddie
murphy came to this one of the shows
that i was at
and eddie was in the back laughing his
[ __ ] ass off at gilbert yeah right
well that there's a freeing nature to
somebody like gilbert in the same way
that later there was a freeing nature to
seeing norm
in the mid zone
post snl to when he clicked in the same
way with uh gilbert there was a window
pre-911
where gilbert kind of couldn't get
arrested he was sort of a
what was thought of as sort of a remnant
of the 80s
kind of comedy boom
and yet had not achieved this cult-like
status around the aristocrats in the
post-9 11 joke that was
like again in in truly serious times
when truly terrible things are going on
there are moments when you can recognize
the value of humor for humor's sake that
right that there is no such thing as
offensive in a world where like i said
there are mass graves being discovered
in buko right now
so and somebody's got to remind you of
that fact you uptight [ __ ] and that's
what gilbert
managed to do
and there's a freedom to doing it when
you're [ __ ] this tall and you look
like a dirty q-tip and you kind of don't
make sense and you're kind of odd and it
gives you a freedom that somebody
beautiful genuinely beautiful like eddie
murphy who's physically a stunning man
in good shape with a great career
can't feel
right he can't get it there you know
it's just something else and so he can
sit back there and detach from himself
and the facade of eddie murphy that he's
had to craft to have a career
and maintain it over these years and the
balance of being treated like an artist
and respected as a comic and [ __ ]
wearing rubber suits and making fart
jokes and yet people finally recognize
that's way more [ __ ] work than a
meryl streep movie and you know at some
point he's going to get an award and
they're going to show clump clips and
it's going to be the highlight of the
[ __ ] oscar night and people are going
to go we were such [ __ ] to not
recognize that's [ __ ] work
interacting with yourself as multiple
characters and you believe every one of
them that's acting [ __ ] off don't get
i'll get out that's a diatribe i'll get
off on that but i will tell you getting
back to gilbert he stole
uh beverly hills cop too that one scene
with him in it i don't know
something in this hand what if i had
something in this hand and then and as i
got what did i have there i don't know
oh that's that click that clip i started
to go around twitter it's already it's
already working its way around twitter
hey he was his
i have to say fort fairlanes one of my
favorite movies
um at talk about you know offensive for
offensive sake and an arc of cancelled
and all that kind of [ __ ] gilbert plays
a dj
in that movie
who uh you know fort fairlane used to
know from his rock and roll days and he
goes and he's investigating this murder
and yadda yadda um and
gilbert has this moment
with with with dice where there he goes
you know look at us a couple of uh you
know dicks except you're a detective and
i'm just a dick
and um he
there's a couple of moments in that
scene
where he drops back from character
and there's such a root there of this
person you're looking at
that it transcends the film like you're
i mean this is a film where wayne
newton's the [ __ ] villain right and
and yet in this moment that that's
genuinely there's a what i i challenge
anybody go watch gilbert gottfried in
fort fairlane so he doesn't have much
work in there he's got a small scene and
a one interaction but he's a pivotal
character
in it
and his
his comfort
as that character is is extraordinary
it's it's beautiful to watch as an actor
and as a performer and as a somebody
recognizing here's the guy who's on
stage just being kind of way over the
top and knowing is i mean literally he
[ __ ] was a duck because his sap his
voice sounds like it or agrees
technically
but
who cares they fired him but right right
well and then and then they hired
someone to imitate his voice because it
was so like yes you know which i would
sue all right
but gilbert wouldn't because that's one
thing i think that you know as offensive
as he was and he tried to be in his
weird like literally if you watch
interviews with him or see anyone talk
about him like gilbert gabriel had a
huge heart like way bigger than even his
stature like he loves that to be willing
right
right it takes that to be willing to
burst people's bubbles because i gotta
say
in this age of like you know comedy
being canceled and edgy and some jokes
hurt and yada yada and is it okay for
will smith to slap someone which it
isn't for telling a joke and [ __ ] like
that joke some jokes hurt and some jokes
don't
gilbert godfrey represented the the
the purity
of
look you need to recognize the uh the
uphill battle that humanity is on all
together nobody's special nobody's more
broken than anybody else everybody
carries their stuff and if you're gonna
use
your weaknesses your your character
traits your uh you know age your race
your gender as a shield against life's
troubles i got news for you it ain't
gonna work life's gonna win you're gonna
have the pain and so i would rather pop
that bubble and then we all share this
together because you don't at least you
don't have this pretense
of a shield that will protect you
because it's it won't yeah
uh betty loco
thanks for five bucks hey i'll get some
gigs on mainstream news to sort them out
tell your manager i said so you can
start with hunter's laptop
oh [ __ ]
yeah
yeah but no yeah
i i've been they're pushing
yeah but have you found it yet have you
found hunter's laptop yet but i mean
i've been looking but uh i haven't i
haven't found it it does not exist all
over the place
all over the place i just can't find it
it doesn't have a pitch yeah yeah you're
not gonna find it
uh
copies of the hard drive because there's
no shortage of people from rudy
giuliani's friends who like to copy and
share child porn apparently but other
than that you're not going to find a
laptop because it never existed
well
and just yeah you know like you know as
we're ending this
tribute to gilbert you know uh yeah two
of my favorite bits that he did was uh
obviously he did uh
andrew dies uh god freed on the channel
nine yes
but
this is one of my favorite bits he did
he was on the air and they had this old
guy on who was trying to tell a story
about joey adams and he was like joey
adams came to my house and then and he's
going and going so after this guy tells
the minute story girl goes
oh oh
i'm so sorry ab
we forgot to hit record can you tell
that story again and it would make the
guy do it how three or four times ago
sorry the tape just broke could you do
it again and i was [ __ ] laughing my
ass off
you know uh gilbert uh
in the same way that
like bobcat goldthwait
uh could also if he broke character to
do a character it made the quality of
the impersonation
extraordinary because it went from
normal person talking to doing
christopher walken or [ __ ] gary
seinfeld when he does seinfeld is
incredible why yeah when he when if i do
it it's just like of course you can of
course you can do it you're not saddled
with some [ __ ] up voice and some weird
way of talking right the idea is that he
lives with this like odd speech
impediment and therefore when he breaks
out of it it's like a [ __ ] magic
trick that was what was beautiful about
him when he would do it when he would do
dice or like ralph cramden or any of
this like he would just randomly do
these characters and nail them
because the character the voice he had
on stage was a character but in the
audience's mind it doesn't register as
such in the same way that bobcat doesn't
and so like bobcat did this one bit
where he would he was talking about
elvis you know mom elvis is a dick and
his mom was like that dick is laughing
all the way to the bank and he's like
what my mother didn't know is that elvis
was on so many drugs he laughed
everywhere he went is the bit i don't
want to scream too much
because i'm singing tonight but uh but
he goes uh when he went into it he put a
another uh
[ __ ] in that blender i'd like to like
when he dropped down from bobcat to that
it was beautiful to watch and the same
thing with gilbert gilbert would
transition into these stellar
impersonations
and it was oh they were always spot on
they were always spot on yeah and it was
and because he was it was like watching
somebody you know who was you watching
me walk around carrying a hundred pounds
like a barbell 100 pound weight and then
they jump up onto a chair you're like
[ __ ] hell
right that's amazing but if somebody
just jumps up on a chair like [ __ ] you
anybody can do that so the
but the but the bar is fake the bar is
styrofoam but the audience doesn't know
that and gilbert could use that to
create just this magical transition it
was great so and you know
if you talk to gilbert
just like you said because zach was a
character if you talked to gilbert tony
he was like he went
this is how he talked um oh yeah okay um
yeah that's all right if you want to do
that yeah
you
i'll
i'll have a slice of pizza and
he was like
nothing like his character in real life
right right
yeah you know like a normal jew instead
of a super jew with the idea that was
his that was this like he had it was the
clark kent jew he was right and then
there was superman jew that was kal-el
you know
right that would come out well you know
you know
he looked through the world of comedy
through the through those eyes that were
always shut too like
right it must be funnier to see the
world like this than because he already
said his eyes should he always says was
that part of his was that part of the
bit too or was that the in reality well
the idea was that he he had to be in him
he had to be disassociated from the
audience and in himself you can't look
right at the audience right and do this
because the the engagement was with some
sort of detect that's what makes you
look crazy on stage that's and by the
way even if you look at richard lewis's
whole stick he has the list and then he
has this whole thing to the side of it
and this whole that
what the audience gets to watch
is a man and struggle with his internal
demons and foibles and weaknesses and
all that kind of stuff that doesn't
really involve them except he's sharing
it with them and if they share that with
him at the same time if they connect to
it it's hilarious
because it's
the rest of the time they're safely
behind the bubble of this guy's
this guy's you know trapped in this and
then you're like oh [ __ ] i'm trapped in
it with him oh wait no i'm not and so
that freedom gives you like a
lighthearted feeling about all of these
frets that you have even if you connect
with every single joke and and gilbert
was uh you know kind of the same way
i'll tell you a funny story how i i was
on this brandon tardik off i'll be the
judge of that
uh
and it was called our last call
and
oh yeah and it was the last three or
four
episodes and
and and the english co-host of mine who
was hot
goes um john so um i hear you're not
gonna be here tomorrow i i hear you're
not feeling well i'm like
what i
really i'm not gonna
so when i go up to the producers i go am
i not hitting my oh no we're gonna
replace you with uh uh our mantle
mountain williams brother for four
episodes to see if he can be good for
anything i'm like okay so i told gilbert
that story he goes well um
i found out i was fired from snl
i got a fan letter and the letter said
sorry that you're sorry you got candy
you got fired
he found out he was fired from a fan let
out
right that's perfect gilbert godfrey by
the way that's yeah absolutely like that
is perfect like his demise to find out
from a fan letter not from the actual
yeah all right absolutely i'm sure his
death was a shock to him too
right right probably probably yeah right
totally caught him off guard
um
and and and here's the thing as a
comedian
i i talk about this all the time now all
of us you know memento moritz murray we
we all have to remember we're gonna die
you have to wear be aware of your
mortality and as comedians
uh the only thing you can ever hope is
that you go out funny and that when
people talk about you
instead of
sorrow
they just keep reliving the joy you gave
them and
with with bob
and with norm and with gilbert
what i think we all carry from them
their gift beyond just the humor that
they made
is the freedom to joke
huh yeah
yeah was this freedom to joke about the
unjokable
that allows you to process their deaths
in a way that you might not be able to
process any others the death of your
family members of other celebrities that
kind of stuff might hit you in a way
that that dampens your spirits but in
their
passing one of the beauties about them
and not all comics have this but they
should
there's an element of just sharing
stories it's almost like vikings talking
about a guy after battle after he died
you know it's like he was a great
warrior and here's why there's a beauty
to that
um and
you know gilbert and like i said we've
lost gilbert and bob and norm in in
relatively short order
and all three of them i think
have that
character
and i can't tell you in this world
how valuable that is yeah
i yeah i totally agree and uh
uh well anyway that's gonna make me ting
her up
yeah
all right
for you and i hate to do this but uh
i get you know i've got to do a sponsor
and then one of them uh no not not r.i.p
gilbert gottfried i hope that [ __ ]
tosses and turns
i'll end them in a box
like you couldn't cremate me i want to
be in a jar just can you imagine a
[ __ ] urn just going what this is
two dicks
uh talking in a in a restroom
please please let there be a talking
gilbert earn you can purchase a year
from now yes
yes
that the lid just opens and does his act
like that
i mean
i might have you're on i think you're on
something i think you're on to something
all right hold on let me
are you guys are you betting men
no death is all around us are you what
are you gonna the way
are you that life is enough of a gamble
are you [ __ ] kidding me
our partners that bet on lines that he
continue to be the number one source for
all your betting needs and sports info
your latest sports developments
including updated on the playoffs fights
and even next season's future
don't forget that baseball's back at the
start of the major league baseball
season is finally here but online.ag is
your continued search for all your
sports wagering needs including live
betting and your favorite vegas casino
and poker games it's super easy to get
to get started so head to the website
today or use your mobile device to join
and use our promo code clns50 that's
clns50 to receive your 50 welcome bonus
on your first deposit bet online.ag
where the game starts
so um
another great one how you know we keep
losing the great ones i mean it's like
in all fairness in all fairness we lose
a lot of shitty ones too we just don't
pay attention yeah right right you just
yeah like that they're [ __ ] yeah they
they croak all the time yeah you're like
i didn't know that guy died he's like
yeah nobody did even his family were
like and his family were like [ __ ] hey
right who was that guy who was that guy
right
it's like getting a new phone you're
like who dis
and like have you seen the oscars and
emmys in memoriam we lose a lot of
mediocre just kidding it's just so mean
but it's true
i'm remembering gilbert in the only way
i can and i if they if they if they
[ __ ] don't
include him in the in memoriam in
everything next year because i think i
don't know that he was ever nominated
for grammy he should have been but uh
for just for the aristocrats for you
know but the for the movie um as as it
was
yeah right
that um if they don't let him
like she's just after somebody striking
someone else and going keep
my wife's
name out of your [ __ ] mouth on live
television facebook by the way twice by
the way yes right yeah in case you
didn't hear them the first time maybe
because your ears were ringing
um jesus uh they should just the whole
thing in memoriam
memoriam should stop and it should just
be gilbert at that dias
a week after 9 11 going a family walks
into a talent agent's office like and
just
roll it
can you imagine a society so free
well
alright pete gilbert gottfried and uh
hal i i you know uh tony and i were
talking about the
atrocious
oklahoma bill that is now banning
abortion that just got signed did you
hear about that
right yeah yeah that that's they're
teeing that up so that uh amy coney
barrett and kavanaugh and the
right-wingers on there can can decimate
roe because what they think is they'll
push this
to back to so what row will happen is
they'll if the if they overturn roe then
what you need is the congress to codify
a woman's right to choose in the con
in a bill and they know they've got
enough people to stop that
and they think that they can stop all
democratic congress people in red states
if they because they're going to vote
for a woman's right to choose even
though the right runs on this whole
freedom
concept freedom for everybody except you
know women who are supposed to be i
guess a brood mayor for brett kavanaugh
yeah i know i do want to invest
in a second johnny heisenberg and chris
rock won't talk about
about the event until he cashes in on
the highest bidder let me just say in
defense of chris rock here
um
why should he give
jimmy kimmel
you know go on his show and give him the
money give him the rings
i i agree with chris rock wholeheartedly
why not
you right he didn't get paid he got hit
yeah he got slapped why not yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah and again i don't know you
don't you don't get to determine
what other people do
especially after they've been assaulted
with their words like yeah like it was
terrible that will smith slapped him but
i believe he should work for me for free
right right right he's watching that
[ __ ] he should come out on network
television and tell me the story
right yeah he should he should sit down
in front of [ __ ] andrea mitchell or
robin roberts or whatever and give a
free
talk on some channel gratis
after getting his face slapped i know
and and
like the only way this would be more
ridiculous is if chris rock
wasn't hosting he was presenting because
he was also nominated for a movie about
slavery
people are like he should work for free
but for [ __ ] sake
do you listen to yourself no he got hit
he can talk about it or not [ __ ] talk
about it it's up to him and if he never
talks about it it's his own [ __ ]
business and if he talks about it and
they they oh they have to give him a
book deal and a million bucks and
they're willing to do it [ __ ] you
yes the man got hit for for a joke
you know i actually i i told john this i
think it was last week when we were
talking about this i was like chris rock
even gave will smith the out like before
before the swing was done he was
starting to make a drive like well wow
wow and he's like he's like we'll just
smack will smith just slap the [ __ ] and
the audience laughed because they
thought it was a bit and at that moment
that moment will smith had the out and
he didn't take it like chris rock gave
him every opportunity that he could to
take that out
because everyone talked about
was that planned or was that not and and
they did never would have had to tell
the story whether it was or it wasn't it
could have lived in mystery and everyone
could always wondered and interviewed
him and asked him questions and all that
[ __ ] but will smith did not take that
out he didn't he he chose to make sure
everyone knew in that room that it was
that's because he really struck someone
and you have to be a special kind of an
[ __ ] to do that but also we talked
about this when john and i had uh um
jack on who's the body language expert
that uh chris as a comedian looked at
jada and will
and went oh i could but all right right
like he moved on
knowing full well that he had the skills
as a comedian and the freedom now
because he'd been slapped he'd been
physically assaulted all better than
their house down both just burned ass
down right and that's and by the way
there's gonna be
after chris does whatever he decides to
do there's gonna be an eight-minute
chunk
uh in his next special people are gonna
will not will
like i i'm gonna line up to watch chris
rock's next special and that he's gonna
do eight minutes on it and that he's
gonna own the copyright on that viral
video for it so it's gonna only come out
they're gonna they're gonna have a team
hitting people with copyright strikes if
they post parts of it and he's gonna
print money on that slap in the
aftermath for a [ __ ] decade and he
should
and then he can sue will
for um for physical assault and for uh
damaging his career because there's this
idea that you know
you know another man comes up and slaps
your face diminishes you in the in the
face of your audience and therefore you
know there's financial harm that could
be done and you had to do financial
cleanup and you had to do other tour
shows that you might not have done but
like he's got room to do all that [ __ ]
again once you strike somebody all bets
are off [ __ ] like that's done like
you don't have any say in this anymore
that's why we have a functioning society
it's yeah no i know i know and but
it's like and i know joni doesn't mean
bad like but i i'm just saying
like like because i thought about it i'm
like why the [ __ ]
why the [ __ ] would i give this to
[ __ ] uh you know um
you know to cbs like you know like i
don't worry
you know no not you know i'll do it and
i'll get paid to do it
i think that's pretty damn smart
considering he's the one yes
yeah do a pay-per-view do a pay-per-view
i mean whatever yeah absolutely cash
cash on that [ __ ] cash in on it
i mean exactly you know
like and anybody again anybody
who decries
him
speaking about
being assaulted on the [ __ ] oscars
and he's he wants money for it like [ __ ]
you like the
the the privilege and
and and slavery analogies are just off
the [ __ ] charts no he can define for
himself what's okay and what isn't okay
end of [ __ ] conversation
like that's so weird
let me uh change this up and talk about
this
uh
how i think you'll love this one
senator marcia blackburn tweets out
tennesseans want a wall on our southern
border on our southern border right yeah
a thousand miles away
from
in her defense
mississippi alabama georgia i'm just
saying
maybe
you should have a right yeah not the
tennessee can brag too much i mean i
would argue as a former kentuckian that
they have every reason to put a board
down there
at least we were a split state during
the civil [ __ ] war i mean if you're
gonna talk about you know the the old
manson nixon line as robin williams used
to call it you know but uh yeah where we
wanna that protection are born okay no
they [ __ ] well don't and the weird
thing is that this what this
is sort of covering is the fact that
abbott has this operation lone star
[ __ ] that he's been doing where he's
using state funds and state personnel to
you know
police the border and he's taking credit
for stuff that cpb and ice are doing
that's federal because he wants to
pretend biden isn't doing anything and
all this [ __ ] they're taking they're
taking credit for [ __ ] that arrests that
are happening in midland texas and get
[ __ ] that i mean that's
like your tennessee is almost closer to
the border right right water
all right well you know it's crazy today
is christ
because every time we hear a story of
like
they see so much drugs fentanyl coming
across the board and like oh my god look
what biden's like he
it's easy coming across the border you
dumb [ __ ] like that's that's what
happened they're stopping it that's the
point
right right
right
and the fact when they when they talk
about it like the amount of uh fentanyl
seized is way up you're like oh so the
[ __ ] was just getting through i see all
right well maybe that's why in that
worst year of opioid deaths we've ever
had
it was a fiscal year from april to april
because that's how they marked it and
it would start in april 2020 under trump
who was went into the next year yeah
yeah exactly during during [ __ ]
ten months of it or nine months of it
like
unbelievable it really couldn't have
been that the guy in charge was watching
fox news too much or anything like that
it sure yeah i don't know
and then the last
right in the last three months of his
presidency he just [ __ ] gave up on
president because he was like
i hate this place [ __ ] this dump well
now we now we know now we know him and
don jr were texted because john jr is
texting mark meadows he's like even like
if they even admitted don junior admits
in that text even before joe biden was
announced president he was like we've
lost and we have to rig this thing
because we're probably all going to
federalism if we don't like oh yeah that
was end
it seemed there's no out it was just
yeah it's just [ __ ] and and here's the
thing again i i say this on my live
stream all the time uh twitch.tv sparks
uh that um
we are so lucky we need to talk about
being grateful full of gratitude a heart
overjoyed
that the people who tried to pull off
this coup were the dumbest [ __ ]
on
earth
it was a family affair of dumbasses they
couldn't hire a decent functioning
person to save their [ __ ] life every
troop member every street general every
steve bannon level
operative all of them to the man
extraordinary fuck-ups like next level
losers
and you know how good i mean how can you
attract anyone
right well that's the thing right he's a
lifelong fuck-up and it's like
just yeah it's just he's a magnet yeah
birds of a feather [ __ ] up together
right but
we are and we have to be grateful we got
i mean obviously when our hitler moment
came
and our nation was on the brink of
losing our phone and government to an
authoritarian scheme
the the people that showed up
were
extras in an abbott and costello short
and i had i coined i coined a phrase
hell speaking of hitler nice i coined
the phrase ninka poop nazis they were
nin kaput now
hitler would have been totally
disappointed in these in these ninja
boop nazis they would he would have just
he would have been like really this is
the best you got this is the best
nazis that you know it's ridiculous yeah
deutschland
it was like it was like benny hill
without any of the uh
the third level wit
right right yeah what it wasn't even
smart and like funny
ah conspiracy of dances
oh yeah don't you think don't you think
though that even though the the coup has
failed like they're still attempting it
right like there's still this soft coup
going on and it's like red state yeah
and it's like the cheeto dust
confederacy is still trying to live like
when they're trying in these red states
past laws to take away women's liberty
they're trying to they're trying to
marry children like it's just cheaters
neither like the south will rise again
see i think those are just uh people who
under trump were given the illusion that
they are you know more popular and not
alone than they actually are and and so
they're they're still swinging for the
fence because they came out of the
woodwork this is stuff they would have
passed in 1975 if they ever had any
movement but the woman's movement you
know in the national organization for
women and the formation of that and and
the society just moving on um
changed too much for them to do it and
now they're just using old-fashioned
legal structures and trying to rig the
system the the irony that trump is
always complaining about how rigged it
is when in reality all we all they did
the republicans got in and rigged this
the supreme court they effectively stole
one seat
and and tried to stiff arm another right
and
and
you know put people on there that are
single serve
uh scotuses they're just there for one
purpose to overturn one particular build
because they've been ineffective at
doing it
nationwide on a personal level because
again this is how you know you've lost a
moral
uh conversation is when you can't
convince people not to do something
based on its merits and some of those
like robbery
we know as human human beings that
eventually you're gonna have to pass
laws around it but even then you can
kind of create all right there's varying
degrees there's grand larceny right and
then there's you know petty theft and
then there's a degree yeah right and you
know sometimes slap on the wrist
sometimes you go to a you know a club
fed
for a couple of years that kind of stuff
but we know that there's varying degrees
in that what they're trying to do is all
or nothing this moral argument that even
that we don't even do when it comes to
murderers so they're trying to they're
trying to all or nothing women
now they may be successful in put in
signing this and getting it through to
the state and they may stage some sort
of big optic [ __ ] running up to the
election because that's really what this
is about this is really about their mo
their voters are not motivated to vote
they think it's rigged they think it's
[ __ ] trump has driven them away from
voting and the only thing
that is going to get them to the voting
booth is oh my god my elective
representatives are finally
passing laws that will eliminate
abortion and so they're like oh we could
have that in our state too so in georgia
and mississippi alabama all these red
states are starting to turn purple they
think this will be the thing that will
motivate their voters to go do this the
reality is though it ain't and they
spent so much [ __ ] time convincing
their voters that the illuminati or the
pentagon is gonna track their [ __ ]
you know
vote and and find out how many guns they
have in the house with a drone and blah
blah that they don't even want to step
outside except to go to a trump rally or
drive around with you know trump flags
on their
and so they're not going to go to the
voting booth because why would you stand
there all day and go to these places and
fill out all this [ __ ] which they feel
like is a intrusion right
registering the vote again a lot of them
got kicked off because they didn't vote
last time even with trump because they
were scared of going in there they
didn't trust it they thought it was all
rigged to start told him
tony liz gallo
john and tony and hal she's been asking
when you please say happy
23rd birthday to my daughter and happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear angelica
happy birthday to you happy birthday
happy birthday
okay now diane you keep saying for me to
read something that you write
and i i don't know what the hell you're
talking about so if somebody can let me
know what she's trying to tell me to
read uh you know i don't know what it is
in the chat
damn lamp yes keeps going read you know
i don't know what she's talking about
hal you know here's the thing yeah okay
yeah you were talking you were talking
about the uh the
voting machines in the voting you know
this is a q anon world we're just living
in it right like it's uh like that's oh
yes
rick schroeder right exactly but you
know back to the oklahoma thing like you
were saying is that is their aim is is
to violate strategically violate roe v
wade like the whole yeah the whole
purpose of that law and for them to sign
that thing is to obviously and legally
the entire thing is to violate roe v
wade you tried to get amy comey barrett
to make the decision that roe v wade
does not exist and that
that's right that's right
and then by the way that that fast
tracks us to all getting a uh an rfid
chip in our neck that's put there by the
government because if the if the
government can establish what your
doctor can or cannot do put in or take
out of your body
and they have the right to intercede and
find out what you're doing it's it's not
a it's a logical slippery slope to uh to
chip in planting this is the this is the
i'm sticking with this is my q
version of
the left side of the thing is that they
want to get rid of abortion because if
they can make you keep an a a fetus in
your body they can of course say well
then we can also redefine a fetus as uh
digital or personal because somebody's
personhood can exist in a digital form
and therefore uh we'll just put a
version of the president in everyone's
body and so you'll all get a brain a
trump brain chip which will allow us all
to uh
to um
that's the shittiest [ __ ] brainchip
right ever yeah yeah yeah
it'll it'll be it'll be fancy cyberpunk
has collapsed into cyberdoor
the best spring chip ever the most
fantastic it's so good
i live on fish delights
robot fish delight robot fish flight
[ __ ] hey hell but i was gonna say
speaking of stupid people and dunces
does sarah palin have a chance
uh
in
in congress sure but it won't [ __ ]
matter she's not gonna take a blue seat
right well the other thing too is alaska
is not alaska's not hip on her at all no
she is she [ __ ] not only is she dumb
and stupid she [ __ ] quit on them
after she lost and she had to go make
money she's like i'm going to go make
money [ __ ] the state of alaska so of
america is not like sarah palin they do
not know and the whole thing is lost
yes the whole family is full of nude
knicks and [ __ ] and they're you know
they're they're like you know the the
beverly hillbillies without the oil or
the attempted class um and yeah yeah no
and again it's like it's kind of like
mtg or even
like herschel walker's gonna lose i'll
just let you know um he's not gonna why
are you getting ahead of the pulls of
warnock
because polls are stupid and they're not
rich yeah because and because it's
georgia and they're they'll have and and
they act they also check as if it's even
so like a couple of days ago there was a
there was a poll about biden and how he
was handling uh the both inflation and
the ukraine bubble this big stack of
things whatever never mind the fact that
he even in that poll averaged higher
than trump ever got he was at 48
and trump never hit 45 45 never hit 45
it was always below 45 and a lot and and
weighted by a majority of shitty ones so
even rasmussen's that would go 52 with
total [ __ ] couldn't drag him out it
couldn't pull him up enough to even the
whole mess out so in this biden poll
that they were talking about
with their if you look at the
methodology of the actual poll it was
530 people
it was 27
uh 25
democrats 27
republicans and the rest was
independence and you're like
independence right yeah yeah right
you're like independents are just people
who are [ __ ] embarrassed they voted
for trump right or hate the system
entirely and they don't like anybody in
charge and then the other thing was half
of the poll was like they were like do
you agree with how he's handling it and
and and they go you know 17 were like
you know absolutely not and 20 percent
were like
sort of not and 10 didn't have like the
the the standard across the thing what's
the economy
part of them right which is also like
okay but that is totally useless
information totally useless that tells
me [ __ ] nothing unless you tell me
why you're against it because i need to
know whether you think he should be
doing more
right or whether he should be less
because that's actually indicative of
the party you know that you will vote
for or the plan that you will vote for
and if he starts talking about i'm going
to do more that'll let you know if
that's going to drive more voters away
or or bring more voters in that will
give you some sort of indication none of
that was in there like and and
like when they got to the questions
about the issues themselves it was like
forty percent i don't know i don't have
enough information to form an opinion
like
[ __ ] off
uh
you're not gonna win you think
yeah
i think so too i i think i think warnock
will pull it up i think i think herschel
walker especially if herschel walker
wins the primary he has so much baggage
and it's all in texas because he doesn't
live in georgia um that's that's really
the thing that's because here's warnock
who is a sitting he's the incumbent he
was elected on a on a special election
which he was supposed to [ __ ] lose
and he won and he's the sitting
incumbent united states senator they're
both they're both african-american so so
you're you're going and he's a car and
herschel walker is a [ __ ] carpet
packer so yeah this idea that somehow
because he went to uga is going to pull
him over the line because let's face it
herschel walker is [ __ ] dumber than
donald trump jr eric trump and don jr
and donald and ivanka all stuck together
like you stream all together and they
got more [ __ ] brains than hershel
he's a he is just he can't even string
sentences together yeah and the idea in
an area where you know three to eight
percent makes a massive difference in
terms of
turnout and function the stacey abrams
georgia is her state and
the active push to eliminate black
people from voting in georgia by the
powers that be over the last last couple
days have activated have actually driven
more black people to want to vote and
care about voting in that state
statistically than others because they
understand that they're they're under
siege effectively in that statement
i'll show you kind of thing
exactly and and and they know the
difference between the the party that's
going to run you know herschel walker is
kind of like you guys like sports right
like oh [ __ ] off you know what i mean
like the like the the pandering aspect
of it that the the attempt by trump and
his crowd to try and go okay we got they
got a black guy and he's very smart do
we have a black guy like it's so awful
and the fact that he's not even [ __ ]
from there and he can't [ __ ] talk and
and he doesn't care to because he's not
even going to debate it's one thing it's
one thing to go you know what
guys just not and there's been a lot of
people like this and functional
politicians in our lifetime that were
not great on the podium
but amazing when it comes to being in
committee like katie porter i you know
katie porter is fantastic but it's not
because she gives great stump speeches
uh you know it's because when you put
her in a committee she comes with
[ __ ] receipts and she's great at
keeping like almost cross-examining
people it's a great skill it's not the
same as you know it's some sort of like
kind of moment that people expect from
politicians and it may keep her out of
the top top echelon over time who knows
but when it comes to rock and and and
herschel walker there's a there's an
element where
there are people both you know the on
the right who are
quite frankly trumpies
in the republican party are going to
look at walker and go wait this guy's
going to be my senator you know if
you're going to talk about side-eye
racism
in the republican party that's the i
mean i guarantee you're shaving three
points off the electorate guarant
[ __ ] t they'll stay at home and any
one of them yes
[ __ ] yeah and that's not even clueing in
the people who
you know again don't trust the system
think they're [ __ ] being tracked by
drones when they go to vote because
they're ki you know they're going to
run you know jade helm all the
conservatives into concentration camps
and [ __ ] like that there's a that's
another two percent in [ __ ] georgia
that's a five percent swing when you get
down to the nuts and bolts actual voters
that's
been specifically affected
by behavior in the state over the last
couple decades and then never mind it
was rigged the whole thing's rigged and
the people who were in charge of
bringing it are still in charge like you
don't go vote because you can't trust it
well the other thing too i think i think
shouldn't be discounted is stacy abram
is gonna actually be on that ballot
she's going to be honest
which is going to be significant that's
right for the turnout in that state in
the in the areas where she didn't just
work hard in this last election or i
mean excuse me in the runoff but the
actual 2020 as well uh and even her
governor's race so like that that
that aspect that she's actually going to
appear on about not just be working for
the ballot she's going to appear on
there it's going to make a difference
too
i think
go ahead john sorry no i was going to
ask how i i'll ask both of you guys
so what's going on with this alvin bragg
thing like so
so first he does the the most horrible
thing and and says oh then you know i
don't have enough evidence then he gets
a lot of pushback now he's saying oh now
we have the evidence so now we're going
to go forward what's going on here guys
you want to i mean in new york i got
mine yeah there's always been
there's always been
a thing around new york uh fear of
pulling the [ __ ]
thread
that there's so much gacked up mob money
and [ __ ] in new york that there's
this kind of wall of like we we can
police this area but we don't go past
that line because once we start
that's it all bets are [ __ ] off it
gets really dirty it drops off into deep
ocean
and in terms of like bragging all these
guys beyond the fact that
the political danger of going you know
that there are trump lunatics and
queuing on creeps that are out there
that are going to think your family are
baby killers and yadda yadda that i'm
sure haunts everybody in the back their
mind when they go after this dick
um that ultimately i think he didn't
recognize
both the parallel evidence on the
federal level
and his own responsibility for doing it
and also i think you know in some ways
he's just a
an absolutist about going after crime
and he's trying to use the use trump as
a way of excusing the fact that he
doesn't go after other crime
so there's that that's the stack but
besides uh what you know and and i'm
sure tony has more to put in there i
would say it's it's a that's why it's a
vacillating complex issue that has a lot
of politics in it but the evidence is
there
well
yeah i think i think bragg made a huge
uh political miscalculation here i think
he i think he calculated that um because
there's a january six select committee
that there's a lot of federal grand
juries happening um that
he could kind of step aside and the sdny
might take the case um he's really i
think he's banking on tisch james uh
capping e-capping the trump organization
in a civil case where he basically
basically just james in the state of new
york is going to take away donald
trump's money laundering machine
essentially i mean that's just james's
aim so when that happens bragg's job's
like well what's my job now to to
criminally charge him for the thing
that's gone so i mean he i think he made
a really bad political miscalculation
here and that's what it is and that's
why pomerantz resigned and then we seen
like a month later we seen the the
letter from pomeranz who was the special
the special assistant uh i think was his
was his title where he was actually in
charge of you know gathering the
evidence and making the case to the
grand jury and we've seen the letter
from promerance basically saying no
[ __ ] there's a crime here and
he's committed a crime
there was no brushing around it and then
after that the the
the
the state governor the new york state
governor kind of got involved they had
meetings and basically the question was
can the governor just tell brad to pound
sand and she'll put another d.a in
charge or can she put a special
prosecutor and when that started i think
bragg really went i've made a big big
huge
uh miscalculation on the politics of
this not just on the legal ramifications
and what all that means so i think
that's why he's backtracking is it's the
political thing because he has to get
reelected essentially i mean eventually
or not right you know probably not but i
mean
that's the thing here is he's a politic
he's a politician even though he's a
prosecutor too he still has to get
elected to that seat so i think he made
a really bad
really really bad mistake i agree
what do you guys i also think like
okay
i was just saying that you know it that
goes in line with the idea that he you
know
as a
as a prosecutor is doing this kind of
like um i'm not
uh this isn't a an aggressive
prosecutorial da's office and so he can
give himself some political room with uh
you know uh like violent crime in new
york and and you know
like lowering prison uh population and
jails and you know extending you know
programs to people like that's what he
ran on and what he can get rid of that
for [ __ ] sake jesus i mean rikers is
right
yeah
and then
right but he
to do that he if he goes i didn't even
go after trump like i'm not in the
business of just going after people just
because like it's got to be
extraordinary and i make it and it gives
him some political wiggle room that get
that patted it for him and other people
are going for it sdny new york's going
after it washington's uh you know uh
going after it so i i don't have to
pick this fight it's already being
handled the problem he has
is that it is an egregious and again
like i said it's once you start pulling
that thread
there's no stopping it yep you know i
mean it's like going after it's like
going after gun trafficking in new york
city once you start
it it goes all the way to tennessee it
goes all the way to mississippi it goes
all the way to texas and you're dealing
with the feds and you're dealing with uh
you know cross state like ghost guns and
modified glocks and people with [ __ ]
trunks their cars selling [ __ ] like a
taxi driver and coming in with suitcases
full arms and they're related to people
and they know cops and they know
people who they entire floors are rented
out to them and buildings owned by the
[ __ ] russians like it's gnarly and
the minute you start down that that's
your life
right and so i think he he also also
felt like you know he can
that's not the job he wants not the job
he came to do so he can just stiff arm
it and go that's other people's problem
what do you think about uh
mark p with the badge just wrote as
terrible a candidate as herschel walker
is he's out polling warnock in gop
voters minds poor character doesn't
matter they just want the candidate of
their party to win
yeah i again i think these are uh early
polls that have more to do with like uh
they're they're calling an equal number
of absolute voters
where that like like these are all
voters who vote every time
that's not who's going to decide this
election and and you're self-selecting
out people who are new to voting voted
in the last two elections for example
but not the last five for example or the
republicans who aren't going to vote
this time who aren't sure they're going
to vote so they hang up so the only
people you're talking to and you're
talking to them as if it's even you're
talking you know we called 100
republicans and 100 democrats well
that's not how it plays out in the
[ __ ] state there might be you know
man-to-man per 100 000 there might be
125 republicans but only 75 of them vote
and there might be
90 democrats but a hundred percent of
them are going to vote and that
that's wha when that factors in that's
why you know you don't know until the
election night and why those kind of
polls are always rough and until they
come up with a way that gets enough of a
broad base or people
like we do pre-votes
you know like hey you know we got to
swath of voters and when you register to
vote you can give your party affiliation
and you can go we want to uh you know
see if you would like to pre-vote for
your candidate of choice
and uh let your voice be known
you know in the early voting a month
beforehand or something like that and
then you really would get an idea of who
showed up but that would still
self-select to the
early voters and not people who vote on
the day so it's it like none of this
ever works out that's why the polls it's
not that the polls are
lying or something it's just that it's
it's a [ __ ] measuring stick it's not
you know there's no real way to qualify
it in any way that matches reality right
now
well and the other thing too is you
can't discount like the pole being uh
ahead for walker you know because you
don't want the slam dunk effect where
like at war knocks 20 points ahead of
walker and everyone in georgia is like
oh well it's a slam dunk so what what
the hell do i need i'm not gonna go
right right you don't you don't want
that slam dunk effect either so the poll
being bad it means that democrats
liberals people who are pro-democracy
who are like we're not gonna let these
fascists take over georgia especially
knucklehead
who who doesn't even live here so to
have that
to not have that slam dunk effect i
think is a good thing so people should
be like well you know maybe walker is
ahead and we should work our asses
harder to make sure we get more
registration and make sure we get more
votes so that way we can yeah that's
effectively like a push
like a like a like a a push pull um
effectively
you know as far as its impact um but you
know the closest thing to this
circumstances is rand paul
and rand paul ran as a carpetbagger in
kentucky as as a side card of mitch
mcconnell in a state where mitch has
outsized control over the electoral
process in the state as far as running
you know raising money and who can do it
and getting to parts of the state and
getting you know
like projects in different in parts of
kentucky that you can go and wave at
mitch has a lot of control over the
course of the state to be able to do
that so he can shepherd somebody in but
even with that rand paul had to come in
on the wings of ron paul and without the
libertarian stretch of ron paul
there is no rand paul who starts from
scratch this there's there's a democrat
very possibly
as a as the second senator in kentucky
you know if if that hadn't happened if r
if rand paul didn't like basically fly
in on his dad's wings and and
that's the closest thing to the kind of
the carpet bagger situation carpetbagger
situation we're seeing in in georgia
with with walker and there is none of
that sports is kind of that fame of that
is kind of that but it's not based on
politics it's not based on his
capability it's not based on his earlier
statements about stuff now
there is a section of voters on the
right
that believe in sort of this libertarian
idea of laissez faire freedom they don't
rule like that they don't legislate like
that as a matter of fact they want to
crawl up your ass
and and and take your temperature every
day um
but
they believe that
like it's okay if herschel walker's the
guy because it's kind of autopilot all
he has to do is stand there and say no
to what the democrats are doing
a warm body a warning
how he didn't he didn't even show up to
the last debate they had
well he won't debate yeah because he'll
yeah
for that very reason because he's not
there's no there's nothing in it for him
in the debate he's not he's not there to
push a policy he's there to stop a
policy and this is where them playing up
cultural aspects like uh like critical
race theory or transgenderism or any of
those kind of things are a way of
spooking their electorate into voting
this is they think that this is the big
threat right and all that all you got to
do is go in there and stop them from
doing this and if you're black while you
do it it really helps us right if our
anti-critical race theory guy is black
we're cool right and that's what they
think is necessary the problem is yeah
is government actually requires
functioning brains to work and there are
a bunch of republicans who still know
that
well you know like i said it's a q anon
world we're just living in it and i'm
glad you brought up herschel walker and
crt because he actually was on stage at
a nazi rail excuse me a trump rally and
he said cgr he said ctr and i thought it
must be the cte that is affecting
herself right he doesn't even know that
it's crt
critical race theory like he couldn't
even get it and there and the reason why
is because herschel walker doesn't know
a [ __ ] and ass thing about critical race
theory what crt means and he doesn't
have to like that's the whole point
when they sat down with them they're
like he's like what's critical race
theory like you don't need to know that
just say it well say it out and then
it's bad that's all you got to say
that's right and they run on a boogie
man theory the republicans do this a lot
they run on a boogeyman theory which is
if you elect me i'll keep the boogeyman
from coming in there is no boogeyman so
when it doesn't show up when they ha
when they're when they're in office
they're like
i did it
and if and if it doesn't show up when
democrats are in office it's because
it's right around the corner it's just
outside they're
right they're trying to trick you into
thinking they're you're not they're
going to take your gu not going to take
your guns and then they'll kind of take
them yeah
the next one [ __ ] obama clinton
[ __ ] carter they were all going to
take my guns and nobody has come for
them yet you'd think some of them would
go oh they don't yeah they don't give a
[ __ ] yeah they're fine with me having
guns especially if i'm in the goddamn
woods
like none of these [ __ ] live in a
downtown area where
like the idea all right look if you have
an ar-15 with two
clips you know two uh magazines sorry
amosexuals two magazines duct taped
together like you're in a [ __ ] call
of duty character because you live so
far out in the sticks that if anybody
comes for you the cops won't be there
for two hours
most people can recognize that what
you're really afraid of is other
rednecks like yourself who are equally
armed and therefore it's not weird that
you want this [ __ ] if you want an
apartment building you're a [ __ ]
lunatic and if you can't hit what you're
shooting at if it takes you 60 shots to
hit something in the city you're blowing
people's corn flakes out of their hands
you know while you're just trying to
there was an intruder it turned out to
be my 15 year old daughter coming in
after
curfew and i just shredded her but uh
but my neighbors now got to [ __ ] do a
bunch of spackling and paint and and
they lost you know their neighbor got
his [ __ ] jaw shot out because i'm rap
rap who's there
you know and that's that's the issue
there is a difference and this was what
obama was talking about about people on
different sides of the gun issue talking
across purposes you're talking to
different people with different needs
and in the cities
you [ __ ] don't need it because the
cops are fairly close i mean they're
literally i literally like where i am
right now in la my house here uh there's
a police station
at the end of the street me too so the
idea
right the idea that there would be a
[ __ ] i'd need a gun is [ __ ] stupid
as a matter of fact it makes me more
endangered because as soon as i call the
cops they're gonna be [ __ ] there and
if i'm like i got this they're going to
shoot me because they don't know the
[ __ ] i am
and i'm just
waving a goddamn gun but if you're in
the woods and i grew up in kentucky
originally
my neighbor's security for his house was
a shotgun if a drive if a if if
headlights came down the driveway that
he didn't know or wasn't expecting he
[ __ ] was jogging up the [ __ ] road
with his shotgun and rightly so because
we had three hail bailey families that
lived up to the hill from
too stupid
you know to be the una bomber but dumb
enough to try and they were scary
[ __ ] and if they decided after a
while they were just tired of being
hungry
there's an off chance they might just
pick a house they think is empty or
you're alone there and come for your
[ __ ] and so a lot of people out in the
woods know that i'm going to call the
cops but they're not going to be here
for a [ __ ] while so i need a gun to
protect myself and there's a whole
conversation to be had right more more
than anything than the shotgun that was
protected it was just the sound the
clacking of the gas gun you know like
that's right it's way more powerful than
any you know bird shots oh
yeah i mean am i no well
you ever see the chappelle bit about
when he moved to ohio and he bought a
shotgun
you know where the the guy and the the
guy in the stores telling him how you do
it you know uh uh
bird shot bird shot uh buckshot you know
like you do you put your you put them in
an order you know so the first one like
and basically it used to be
uh rock salt bird shot buck shot that's
that's your three line and then and then
it's just buck [ __ ] shot buck shot right
um and then you know that's it
my teeth fixed
and and uh
my neighbor used to run out he would
have two he would have rock salt
in his gun he had a double barrel
shotgun he would run out there he'd rock
salt in both of them
and then he had two buckshot shells in
his pocket just in case and so you
yeah case that in case you weren't to be
stopped and that was i mean and again it
wasn't because he was a [ __ ] crazy
gun nut or he thought the government was
coming for his [ __ ] and somehow over
time people like that have been
bullshitted by the republican party into
thinking that i give a [ __ ] i'm a
democrat i voted for joe biden i voted
for barack obama i would have voted for
[ __ ] carter if he'd happen in my
lifetime i voted for bill clinton like
i'm not gonna i don't and i have no
interest in taking away your [ __ ] when
you live out in the goddamn sticks it's
just reasonable behavior and and by the
way if you're an absolutist with the
second amendment then don't skip past
the well-regulated militia part
well regulate me if you're an absolutist
i'm a purist they always talk about
words you mean words matter you mean yes
great
yeah that's why they wrote them the [ __ ]
down
come on
come on that the words the federalist
paper told us about the three of liberty
shut the [ __ ] up that didn't i don't
want to hear about the first and the
first [ __ ] draft or you got to talk
to me about the fact that jefferson put
the end of slavery in the original draft
and the southern delegates scratched it
the [ __ ] out right right and and that's
not taught in schools and you know why
it's not taught in schools so the
southerners don't [ __ ] feel bad one
of the reasons why they can't make them
feel or you can't make them right
one of the reasons
why crt why crt is sort of coming back
around and why things like the 1619
project which i believe are largely a
historic and one-sided the reason
they're making a rise is because there's
such an imbalance created by the fact
that we didn't want the south to feel
bad about themselves so we tiptoed
around well we had slavery and then we
had a civil war about it and that's
quits we called it quits we don't need
to talk about it anymore some people
fought for that and some of them thought
states rights but the majority of it was
about slavery we don't like slavery and
that's done and it's 1965 and [ __ ] this
and that's how and we just to try and
play nice with people who
today would love to have slavery back i
know but
lost [ __ ] lost and who were at that
time by the way putting statues of
robert e lee and [ __ ] around going if we
get another shot at this
uh
right exactly the chess pieces are still
on the board for hal and tony i do have
to end the show so how plug
your gig tonight and plug anything else
um i will be on at three o'clock for my
regular show and then tonight i'm at the
whiskey um it's ultimate jam night and
we are um
we're all doing songs uh around you know
because taylor hawkins passed we're
doing um
songs that were recorded at sound city
so it's a bunch of different musicians
and uh and guitar players and basically
everybody gets together nobody has
played these songs before we just get up
on stage and play them together for the
first time or they throw the musicians
together and so i'm doing tonight i'll
be doing um uh sober by tool
nice and uh
back for more by rat because they were
both both those albums
you sound uh you sound better than
piercy
and so i'm doing both of those tonight
yeah okay and then uh the 27th 27th at
the viper room nerd halen um will be
performing at the viper room yeah but
tell us about flank and infotainment
yeah infotainmentwars.com which is my
youtube channel or fwank.comfwanq
of course.com because it's as tony says
it's it's q's world you're just living
in it
that's right flank um we'll take you to
twitch.tv sparks and you can join there
uh and subscribe and if you have amazon
prime it doesn't cost you a dime that's
the great thing about twitch you can
just use one sub a month and subscribe
to a channel and it should be mine
because hassan's got too much [ __ ]
money for a marxism [ __ ] that guy [ __ ]
that guy [ __ ] that guy
that you want to plug yeah sure every
single week that you can you can watch
me youtube twitter twitch live every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
and now on the midas touch facebook page
we're over there live as well nice two
hours that's great monday through friday
two hours and i yell and scream the
microphone and i don't i don't stop
and we keep going because the democracy
is worth it so i think i think you guys
i agree
all right good on you
thank you so much both of you for coming
on i really appreciate it we'll talk to
you soon absolutely all right
so that was a great show i want to thank
my guests today
um
uh
hal sparks
and uh you know and tony and i also want
to thank
my moderators
um
benny loco and nikki b
and uh and then also uh
my sponsor bet online.ag
and again
my
condolences to the godfred family to his
children
and to uh
and to his wonderful wife dara
kravitz god freed and uh i seriously
it's
it was uh it's shocking news shocking
news i knew gilbert
uh
i knew him very well and i
got the chance to do stand-up with him
and he was truly one of the
comedian
legends of our time and i'm very
saddened to hear
about his passing
so uh
that's it for today i will be back on
thursday at noon
pst uh and uh
with the member of congress
and then i'm sure another great guest
all right this is stuttering john saying